it's a big adventure for frank calizania
from malawi and londiwicosa from south
africa to be in berlin away from their
jobs back home in africa
oh it was a dream come true and
more especially for me this was my first
time to get out of
our country
and of all places coming to berlin in
germany i was one of the best things
that has ever happened to me in my life
they both work full time back home frank
for the tax office and landiway for the
finance ministry here in berlin their
students once again briefly along with
three dozen africans from 13 different
countries their professors are teaching
them a lot of new things
one issue is taxation of cross-border
transactions most of the students have
not dealt with international tax
questions before
it's the first time they hear about it
those who are experts on corporate taxes
have never had to worry about income tax
issues
how to tax people working in one country
when they live in another
for ideas on how to improve the
situation in africa frank and his
colleagues draw on european examples
it's important for them to change the
perception of taxation among people back
home in many countries the population
considers taxes as a form of corruption
or even theft
i think that we need to
make people understand what's happening
with their tax money i think from a
government perspective we need to start
educating people in terms of how we're
spending the money and where the money
actually goes to just to ensure that
people who actually receive the money
are actually spending it for
the right course most of the
people back home
they have a negative perception of
taxation and therefore in the end we
have low compliance they simply think
taxes are just a form of government
stealing from people they do not
appreciate the fact that taxes are for
them
like the taxes that pay for the student
dorm they're staying in it's basic but
sufficient for their brief sojourn in a
few months they'll be returning to their
jobs in africa and hopefully they can
apply what they have learned